hi this is International master David
Bruce for chess comm and today you're
going to learn a very very important
lesson which is how to checkmate with
king and queen against King if you
already know go take your whining
complaints elsewhere and I'll make a
more advanced video for you next time
but if you don't know
gather round because this is actually
one of the most important things to know
how to do in chess now the checkmate
with Queen against King aided by your
own King is really really really
fundamental in chess because a lot of
chess games are going to come down to
the final pawn and you're gonna have a
situation like this where you've got one
pawn left on the board and you managed
to get it down to the end you promote it
to a queen and then you need to get to
work
checkmating with your queen and king um
so let us put the Queen back where we
want her alright so if you have this
situation here which you'll have many
times you want to checkmate with king
and queen against King the first thing
that you need to do to be able to get to
anything is to know what your
destination is and where it is right so
you can't start making a checkmate
unless you know what a checkmating
position would look like so that makes
sense if I start just moving the Queen
randomly do you know if I'm getting
closer or further to checkmate right now
what if I do this do you know if that's
closer or further checkmate you can't
really know unless you know what the
checkmate looks like so the first thing
you need to do is you need to try and
imagine in your head how you can set up
a checkmate with the king and queen
against the king and I suggest that you
try and imagine that for yourself before
I show you because that's how you're
going to figure out all the other
checkmate right is you have to figure
out how could the forces I have create
checkmate
then what squares would they need to be
on and then try and find a path to that
position so pause your video if you want
to imagine how this would look and I
will now show you a couple checkmates
first of all really hard to checkmate
the King in the center of the board
because he's got eight possible moves
right
so we're gonna try and checkmate him
either on the side or in the corner
okay corner is the easiest so let's put
him over there now our queen won't be
able to checkmate by herself so we
should put our king somewhere near him
but not necessarily on him because
that's illegal right Kings can't stand
next to each other so we're gonna put
the king near the opponent's king any of
these four squares that I'm highlighting
would do okay so the Kings near the
opponent's king and now our king is
covering two of the four squares that we
need to cover right we need to cover all
three squares the opponent's king can
move to and the squares on so that means
our queen just needs to cover these two
squares here ah there are a couple ways
she can do that right one would be if we
got her anywhere on this back rank since
she moves sideways she would cover both
squares easily the other option is to
put her next to the opponent's king like
this she'll cover these squares and also
this square while being defended by our
King very important if the King was over
here it looks like your queen is
covering everything she needs to in
checkmating the King but she herself is
not defended and that would be a failure
for her so this is a checkmate and this
is also a checkmate from this square
here she also covers everything she
needs to and is defended by the King if
we put the King out in the middle of the
board
the checkmates are gonna look pretty
similar the best spot for our King will
be to cover all three spaces in front of
the opponent's king and then if we put
our Queen on the back rank that would be
checkmate like this right each of them
covers one rank or we could put the
Queen in front of the opponent's king
and she would cover all three squares
but notice that now if she were to the
side of the King she doesn't quite cover
all the squares that she needs to he can
escape over here also notice that if
your King isn't right in front of their
King and you try and do the pack rank
checkmate the King can come out to the
square here so you have to be a little
bit careful here if they're in the
middle and make sure that you're really
covering every square in the corner it's
a little bit easier now let's go all the
way back to the beginning and try and
move the
towards the side of the board the one
hint that I want to give you right away
is that checking your opponent doesn't
mean that you're closer to checkmate
check and checkmate don't actually have
that much to do with each other in terms
of forcing things so your opponent's
king is best placed in the middle of the
board worst place in the corner and
second worst place on the side so if you
check him notice how his king is able to
stay right where he is in the center
right we're just checking him
accomplishing nothing okay but now
imagine that in this position we start
off by trying to take away some of these
squares from the opponent's King right
so the first thing you might do is try
and take away these two squares with
your queen so you can move her in here
and she cuts off those two squares now
your opponent's King moves here and you
want to take away this square - right so
actually instead of checking him what
you're going to continuously do is
attack all the squares around him
forcing him further and further out of
the center
now his King could choose to move this
way and again we're gonna take the last
Central Square away from him right so
we're going to move our Queen here and
now the King could step back and we're
gonna move our Queen here cutting off
this rank and taking this square away he
moves this way we come here and you
might see a pattern emerging so I'm now
going to go back and tell you what that
pattern is from the very beginning the
pattern is you always want to place your
queen a knight's step away from the
opponent's king that way she will cover
the most squares that he wants to step
on and restrict him the most so simple
we move our Queen where she's a nice
square away from the king he moves we go
to where she's a nice square away from
the king he moves and whether he moves
sideways or backwards we always keep
this same relation it's actually never
going to be checked we're always just
going to be taking squares away from him
and you see we can do this all the way
till we get to the end of the board and
you see I'm pushing the king further and
further towards the corner now me
personally once I've got the King on the
edge of the board I don't worry about
forcing him into the corner I would just
bring up my King to help with the
checkmate
um but if you want to force him into the
corner you can do so but the one thing
you need to realize is that you don't
want to take away the very final Square
from him because this is sail mate and
that is the number one danger in this
endgame is that if you take away every
square the King can go on when you're
not checking him that is a draw by
stalemate and you don't want to do that
so you have to leave him in a cage
that's at least two squares big if you
leave him in a caves it's only one
square big he can't breathe just fix
Yates and you don't win the game what
you need to do is leave him in a tiny
little cage of 2x2 and then March your
king up right and he's just stepping
back and forth nothing he can do your
king goes exactly where he wants to go
right either of these squares these King
moves here now you can choose your
flavor of checkmate right back rank or
smush made right two choices um now
let's quickly do it again try and um
we'll mix it up a little bit I will just
put the White Queen here on the first
move and now in your head try and call
out in advance every move that I'm going
to make before I make it okay so first
thing I'm going to do is here right
taking away three central squares and
being a nice move away from him he comes
here I'm gonna follow my pattern
now this is really weird played by him
he's found a way to keep you from
following your Knights pattern so that
shows that in chest you have to be
willing to adapt a little bit your best
move here is going to be to just cut him
off by taking the second row so you just
play Queen here King comes here and now
you've got him cut off on the second row
and the way I finish this is I just
bring my king out and I chase him down
with my king and eventually he has to
turn back you can't run away forever and
then checkmate okay one more time take
all the moves for white okay we're gonna
start with the Queen with whites Queen
being over here all right so now White's
move right here also good moves would
have been here or here which would also
be a knight's move away right but I like
to right away force them out of the
center
all right try and predict every move I'm
gonna play Queen B for Queen e3 Queenie
for Queen e5 simple right Queen a for
Queen f5 Queen f6 Queen g5 and now just
time to bring in that King
here it comes folks I think you all know
what the last few moves are here you can
do it however you like now excellent and
that is really good I suggest that you
actually practice that a little bit okay
so there is actually a tool that you can
use on chess comm that allows you to
practice fundamental positions such as
checkmating with a queen so why don't
you give it a try you can try this even
with a free membership and just what you
want to do with these kind of basic
positions when you want to learn them is
you want to do it successfully at least
three times in a row before you move on
to something else so you've just watched
this video on how to checkmate with king
queen against king don't assume that
you've learned it unless you can
successfully do it three times in a row
okay and really you know five or six
times is not a bad idea it won't take
you long once you get the hang of it all
right I trust you will find this very
very useful and good luck in your
studies and your games I hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll see you
around on chess calm